on episode 50 of anime culture corner
reads an
entire manga in one day and gets super
hyped about it and wants to make a video
record of ragnarok i've been hearing
about this manga for a while now from
friends and from masked man and just all
over i see this guy
who's great by the way after i read it
and since i recall a month or so ago
that an anime adaptation was announced
for 2021 for record of ragnarok
i thought there would really be no
better time to talk about it plus the
second choice on my recent poll was to
talk about another anime
so this is the one get ready for record
of ragnarok guys
i think that this manga is easily one of
if not the best
tournament style manga i've ever read
because the thing is
record of ragnarok is basically nothing
but
a huge tournament it doesn't lose focus
by trying to do too much outside of the
fights
on top of the fact that the battles are
insanely hyped
and interesting and dynamic and just
incredible overall
in so many different ways that i'll talk
about in this video
like dummy hype bro like it easily has
some of the best fights i've ever
witnessed and they aren't even animated
yet i mean just look at the length of
the video
the whole run time from here on out is
literally just gonna be me talking about
the fights and record of ragnarok and
why they're amazing
and so the fact that i'm dedicating a
whole video just to the fights should be
a testament to their um
incredibleness what's the right word
there
anyway to the 97 of you who aren't
subbed yet make sure to like and
subscribe if you want to see more
content like this and support the
channel
let's roll my brand new intro
[Music]
the premise of record of ragnarok is
quite simple
every 1000 years all of the gods nordic
hindu buddhist greek you name it gather
together to
decide the fate of humans basically
whether they'll completely annihilate us
or
let us live for another millennia and
this time they
just got fed up i guess and decided to
exterminate us bugs
but brunhilds one of the valkyries
voices another possible option
a tournament a competition a battle
between the gods and humans and if the
humans lose then
sure they'll get exterminated they
didn't really deserve to live anyway
right
but if they win then they can keep
surviving they can survive another
millennia
and this develops into ragnarok a
tournament consisting of 13 battles
between mankind's 13
greatest fighters of all time and the
gods 13 best
from names like jack the ripper to adam
like
like og adam and eve adam to gods like
thor
and zeus it's similar to the fate series
in this way
how humans are bringing back basically
their best heroes of all time to battle
it out against each
other but fate zero and fate stay night
have all those like complex plot points
and things you have to think about
but record of ragnarok is way different
in its simplicity
it's literally just 13 one-on-one fights
to decide the fate of humanity
and you might be thinking wouldn't that
be boring just
fighting well if you thought that then
you're dumb
because it's awesome oh and it goes way
deeper than just that
the first good part about record of
ragnarok is that they don't really play
around with those filler fights you
normally see in tournament arcs in big
shonen
where our main character has to fight
someone who we know they're gonna be
but they just do it just to show that
they're getting stronger and crap like
that
but here we know from the gecko that
everyone is op
but there's still that underdog element
as human fights the gods as humans
challenge the arrogant gods who never
would have thought humans could even
begin to touch them
and that underdog element is surely one
of the best parts of tournament arcs
the second good part and arguably the
best of all
is that each battle is crafted out in a
very specific way
so that the two fighters the god and the
human have very unique reasons
not just for fighting in general but for
fighting their opponent in particular
the author very wisely chose who would
go against one another
so that the fight never felt like just a
fight but more like a clash of the two
characters existences
in every battle we see the backstory of
the two characters which gives their
purpose
the reason for their existence and how
they became such a legends
i'll use the very first fight thor vs
lubu as an example
both characters had never really found a
challenge in their lives
they always lived at the top of the food
chain and the only word to
really describe the both of them is
bored
we witness this through their
well-fleshed out backstories and as they
begin to fight more we see their
fighting spirit
something that has never been seen that
they themselves have never experienced
come out as they finally find a worthy
challenger
and it ends up in this like super
man-to-man battle of strength and
putting your all into this battle
it reminded me a lot of like jojo i
don't think this is unintentional either
like literally one page in record of
ragnarok had bro saying
or aura and rapidly punching the enemy
not saying this is bad or anything it's
sick but
you know it's just something funny and
the backstories get much deeper than
this as well
there's hercules and his path to godhood
and righteousness and jack the ripper's
tragic tale of abandonment and it all
builds up to these and i know i've said
this a lot incredible fights
from adam having one of the sickest
quotes of like all time where he goes
is there any man that needs a reason to
protect his own children
as he claims all of humanity has his
children
all of humanity who's sitting in the
stands watching him fight
and they're all their balling yourself
included crying
out for the fighter of humanity as he
challenges the greatest god of all time
it's just magnificent the place they're
fighting in valhalla
basically holds the souls of everyone
who's ever lived
so in the stands it's people who the
humans knew in their lives
and people who can finally see the
fighters fulfill their dreams
or something they never achieved in
their life one of the fighters for
humanity is sasaki kojiro
who went his whole life losing against
enemies but continued
even to learn sword styles after death
and we see how his former swordsman
adversaries now
acknowledge that he's far beyond any of
them and is truly untouchable under the
heavens
it's just immensely rewarding to watch
the results of the battle
ironically whether the humans win or
lose
something amazing about the writing is
that no matter who wins or loses
both sides leave satisfied it was funny
each time the battle finished below the
pages of the manga were just
fs in the chat like yeah man respect to
those guys
you can never really be upset with the
results because both sides put their
lives on the line
to truly fulfill the dreams that extend
beyond the mere human lives they had
as you see the best fighters of humanity
truly get their chance to go all
out against someone who's even beyond
them
and bringing it back to thor and lubu
the loser who i won't mention of course
didn't really lose they disappear into
the afterlife
knowing that they finally found someone
who could challenge them and make their
wish come true
with adam we see how his body one molded
after god himself
can be finally used to fight the gods to
defend his progeny from the betrayal he
experienced himself
and there's even times when you're not
even rooting for humans
jack the ripper because both characters
are so fleshed out that oftentimes it's
just a matter of who you find
cooler the results can go either way and
i'll gladly accept
like all of the fighters are so
interesting and so entertaining
and what i'm trying to say to encompass
everything is that the battles
as the only real driving force of this
manga are so multi-faceted and
rich in backstory and entertaining that
it's truly a sight to behold
if you're looking for something hyped to
pass the time with easily
top tier battles like the manliest of
manliest stories and fighters
check out this manga or wait for the
anime to come out your choice
but you won't want to miss out on record
of ragnarok
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses